meanwhile the white house doubling down
after biden called governors who ended
their mass mandates as quote pushing
neanderthal
thinking for actually wanting their
states to reopen and
actually wanting to let people make
decisions for themselves
uh that sounds a lot like deplorable joe
anyway joining us with reaction texas
governor greg abbott
uh well governor if you're a neanderthal
i can only imagine what they call me at
the white house
i'm sure it's not very pleasant but i
can handle it like you can i know you're
a tough guy
uh but let me first start with this
report we just had
because these policies are greatly
impacting
your home state and we have over 100
people now testing positive with covid
you know the biden is attacking you
because you want to open your state
his masked mandate he wants he wants
draconian shutdowns meanwhile he's
letting people in that have not socially
distanced have not been tested and
are not wearing masks right
two things first the president obviously
doesn't know what he's talking about as
it concerns
what's going on in texas because if you
look at the
recoveries that we've had if you look at
the reduced hospitalizations if you look
at the vaccinations that we've
administered
you will see that hospitalizations are
going down we're getting in the last
week more than 1.2 million people were
vaccinated
almost a quarter of a million people
were vaccinated in one single day
and about half of our senior population
has received a vaccine shot so
as far as addressing cobit by the state
of texas is concerned
we're doing a good job however the
president is making it far
more difficult and he's endangering not
just texans he's endangering
people across the entire country because
what has happened
is people come across the border and the
border patrol will process their
paperwork
they get on a bus and they scatter
across the entire country
and as you now know many of them have
tested positive for covet
so what president biden is doing he's
allowing people to come in here
who are testing positive for covid and
they're going
across the entire country who knows how
many people they are infecting
this is a very dangerous situation we're
calling on the president
to end this scheme right now
yeah well by the way governors like
yourself and
every state had its difficulties every
state hit the bumps on the road
but you like governor desantis like
governor gnome and many other republican
governors you protected
the elderly population in the great
state of texas
but on the other hand people are dying
they're suffering their business are
shutting down
jobs are lost wages are gone and they
want to get back to living life
everybody understands governor in the
state of texas about mass and social
distancing
so you're saying to use your good common
sense and the knowledge we've
accumulated correct
correct sean texans as well as americans
they've been going through this
challenge for an entire year now
they've heard the messaging from doctors
top to bottom and they know exactly what
to do
to be safe until they get a vaccine wear
a mask
maintain your distance wash your hands
every every person can
rattle that off immediately but
importantly as you pointed out
while some states have dozens of
different categories of people that they
provide vaccines to
our goal was singular and that is to
reduce deaths and hospitalizations
all the math shows that almost all of
the people who are hospitalized
or lose their life to covet are 65 and
older that's why we have really
accelerated the process of vaccinating
those who are 65 and over
we every person who is 65 and older in
texas who wants a vaccine
will get a vaccine by the end of this
month all right great job governor
abbott
and um our best to our friends in the
great state of texas
you're making the right decision just
everybody be smart we know the rules
take care protect the elderly population
thank you sir
all right